So, in this final sub-mar, sub-lecture about cameras,
I just wanted to showcase to you the importance of different types of sensors.
We discussed the photographic process that was applied to both digital and
film capture.
Also discussed how sensors work in a camera.
We looked at different types of color filters.
Talked about their filtering.
Discuss in brief CCD and CMOS sensors.
And also discussed a little bit about the camera raw format.
The goal, of course, of all of this was for us to now learn as much as we could,
about what a camera is, and how rays of light are converted into pixels.
We have looked at how to do pixel-based processing before.
We know how light is captured, in this instance.
So now we will take a little bit more deeper look at
doing computational photography.
So in the next class we
will actually get into doing some computational photography.
We'll start with learning a lot about things like blending and fading.
Eventually we'll come to look at things like oh,
how can we actually build panoramas and high-dynamic range imaging,
some of the well known examples of computational photography.
Of course, I'll be exploring and actually also showcasing to
you a wide variety of other sets of examples in the same way.
Again, just wanted to list a few examples of books that you could look at that
give you more details about both cameras, the processing pipeline,
and also, you know, how photography really works.
While this class is not really about photography, these are foundational things
that we will actually be playing around with a lot.
Again, look for additional details on the website for the class.
And remember, always have fun computing with photographs.